that's right i'm noticing that you and i
have a similar look today uh we do and
we don't you you have like sort of the
buttons of a pea coat
on a flannel shirt uh which i find very
strange
yeah i don't know you throw them by the
button i like the button it's something
that's something
well i guess i guess i'm a little
confused as to whether it's a shirt or a
jacket and by the way that's fine yeah
that's fine i'm okay with that it's sort
of a shacket or a jerk
right
who makes that who makes that this is a
company called hartel
which is a friend not doing plugs no
we're not doing something he's a friend
he's a friend of mine uh i will say
johnny i will say that i that just this
morning there were two more of these
buttons here and here they both came off
no i ripped them off they're in my
office right now why did you because i
noticed what i was doing on my desk it
kept it just clicking
i thought i just ripped them off yeah in
a rage i can bring them in no commonly
get scissors or you just pull them right
off i just pulled them off i just popped
them savage sounds like
you're i could rip thread you're a hot
tub dude you're gonna let me know you're
just drawing your shirt
no because that's what you're going for
you're going for a shipwreck look
that's that's why you have the one the
one remaining button i don't know how
hard tells us
a shipwreck jerk a shipwreck jerk yeah
all right launch into your thing what do
you got ah today we're going to the
phones we're going to go to the phones
live today we're going to do something
special we're going to go to the phones
for
hot takes we're going to get hot takes
from people and we're going to we're
going to just talk to people this is
very exciting this is very exciting
megan what are we doing today yeah we're
going to take some random callers i got
you guys a 1-800 number and uh so we're
just going to tweet it out
and instagram
whatever [ __ ] has off from work today
yeah right right right and uh we're
going to get your hot take you can talk
to us about uh you know talk to us about
covin your cure for covin you might have
and we will spread that misinformation
uh what's your hot take whoopi goldberg
should she have been suspended yes or no
what's that take here you gotta take on
the holocaust that's not gonna pan out
well all right uh okay
you know what i'm sad though is i don't
have those
i want those like the operator boards
you know with the plugs that i have to
like unplug and plug back oh i know i
know wouldn't that be cool that'd be
cool that would be cool yeah and your
arm would get tired those things were
those things were amazing manny an
operator died of
arm exhaustion all right
yeah he's on fire i'm on fire
we're brought to you by adderall
landlines people landlines taking a wild
guess who might be calling picking up
the phone and answering okay
we're just going to tweet we're going to
try all right let's fire the number out
all right i'm not fast okay
okay wait wait wait wait wait before oh
wait before you send it don't send
anything out okay let's have our first
let's go so fast that i could how could
i even have possibly sent i am so i'm
ready
oh my god
here's a question though because this
could be fun
should we
but should we all do it at the same
exact time
and then see
who's
who saw it where first the first caller
saw it on
charlie's or glenn's or rob's feed
i don't know just to add an extra what i
mean
that does seem like a very exciting game
yeah that does all right fine i'm ready
to press okay
i'm going to push okay but i haven't
pushed cherry yet wait hold on oh cause
you're going to a story i think the
story is the better i'm on a post oh
okay you still got a shirt well why
don't we do this why don't you go post
yougo uh story and i'm already in the
post
i'm pushing the button let's go let's go
share that's what it is there we go now
guess what i'm
what if we just sit here in silence for
like 20 that's that's the kind of thing
that the person always says and then you
know all of a sudden
like they have too much pizza they're
like well what if this machine doesn't
make enough pizza and then they're
buried in pizza that's what the person
on their pizza says um let's go to the
phones
megan
who's called it's the switchboard
lighting out there's what's more
lighting up how are your arms are they
tired
are you tired megan's gonna go into some
sort of uh
i'm really nervous about this this is
gonna require me to talk because i have
to pick up the phone and say hello to
people
you're already talking you're talking
right you got it down you got it down do
my best uh i'm i'm you're also doing a
story i'm i'm doing a story here guys uh
just because
what's the story
i i just put call this number now we're
taking calls for the on the podcast for
real
okay should i put for real i will just
share your story which will be
oh well i have to tag you in order to do
that oh no i already pushed the [ __ ]
okay it's fine that's fine [ __ ] two [ __ ]
damn it oh glenn glenn
this is really interesting i i rage a
lot in my life i don't know why
yeah i get very frustrated
i get very frustrated about things and i
rage but it's been really interesting
because you know this is something i
don't like about myself and i want to
fix it
but i haven't been able to address it
yet or figure out how to fix it yet um
nor have i tried um
but you know as you know i broke my
collarbone two weeks ago
uh it's getting better thanks for asking
um
and and and tweaked my back more about
your collarbone no and i can't wait to
hear so i can't rage oh you can't raise
because
because when i scream or rage or get
angry
when i express myself physically or
vocally i can't because it hurts my my
collarbone or my back or both usually
both right but
if you lean into that it might be even
funnier because then you would have rage
against your shoulder and back and forth
my own body yeah and i'm like ah ah god
damn it
just a feedback loop yeah which will be
very funny for us hey guys we've got
callers
megan
those arms are flapping get this plugs
and plug in we're going to the phone
it's going to be a [ __ ] show
i don't see a phone so that's so we're
going to hear them in the middle of the
internets
through the internet an internet
telephone
internet guys will hear it ring in your
headphones too when they when they call
in and oh mental data
[Laughter]
let's get them let's get that first
caller any minute now
the first ever caller on the only sunny
podcast yeah this is exciting i've never
talked to a fan before i don't
yeah
you don't talk to anybody
no i don't really leave my house
uh no i'm joking
of course i have
oh
that sounds like something that's a cool
sound let's let's answer it answer phone
answer thank you for calling the always
sunny podcast you're on with rob charlie
and glenn hello
hello who is this all right you're our
first caller first caller oh my god
i saw rob's tweet and i was like
what's your name
my name's mandy amanda you have just
made my day
yeah
god bless you mandy we didn't know whose
tweet would get seen first or
text or post so rob is the winner of our
little game here another game tonight
amanda you're the big winner today
what are you telling us where are you
where are you from
i'm from like
the detroit area
in michigan no you know what i notice
about detroit i i know a lot of people
from detroit but they're actually not
from detroit they all say
the greater detroit area right yeah i
find that very it's like detroit has a
lot of areas yeah what what area was
because everybody left actual detroit
and they spread out into the area yeah
all right mandy what's your hot take
what you got today what what do you want
to talk to us about something go ahead
go
um
oh my god i have no idea that's fair
that's fine yeah that's that's fully
expected you dialed in a friend you just
you just you just called and now you're
i really did i like freaking out yeah i
get it listen we start the podcast every
day with this exact same dilemma what
are we gonna do what do we have nothing
to say like you know what i mean so
manny what do you do for a a living you
have a job
yeah i work at panera bread
this episode is brought to you by panera
bread i like that fuji apple salad
chicken salad i do are you at panera as
we speak like in the back room
no no thank god i don't work today okay
wait mandy can i ask you a question
about the fuji apple chicken salad that
i've had many times from panera bread
uh here's my here's my question for you
mandy um did they at some point go from
putting fresh fuji apples in the salad
to putting dried apples in the fuji
apple salad because i hadn't had one in
a long time and i had one not too long
ago and it wasn't fresh apples in there
anymore it was dried apples what's going
on there mandy
well damn um do you know what i'm
talking about like
i've i've worked there for about five
years i think we've always used dried
apple chips always unless they're in la
they're using fresh ones whoa
well that could be that could be a
detroit area they're drying their apples
right
when did you start watching uh it's
always sunny in philadelphia
um
my god it was a long time ago it was
right after i watched horrible bosses
nice i was like
i like the charlie guy and i gotta see
what there we go
right what else is that yeah yeah
now that was that was a long time yeah
that was a long time ago but it was also
do you mind if i ask how old you are
mandy
23. oh my god
so you started young i started watching
young
well mandy thank you for calling wait a
second oh okay i was about to boot you
right out of here
wait a second mandy what did you think
about coffee town
i don't think i actually have seen it
but it is on my letterbox list to watch
it you're in it oh it's all right all
right it's fine you can skip it man
mandy have a great day in the detroit oh
you got something else let's go hot dick
oh i was just gonna say i'm so glad that
you guys are recording it it's like it's
been so fun to watch it i like i keep
tweeting it
i feel like i'm like watching my fun
drunk uncles like talk
i've always wanted to be somebody's fun
drunk uncle yeah yeah i am someone's
[ __ ] drunk uncle um now uh
we're not currently this is vodka but
it's a good suggestion and we're going
to take that we have lots of colors
though mandy and you're you're the first
at the tip of the mountain so thank you
for calling and uh and we're going to
move on good luck at banana bread and
thanks for watching the show thanks guys
bye bye
okay panera bread would you say banana
bread i think i said panera bread they
sound like banana bread good luck there
working at the banana bread company and
uh good luck with the dried apples that
was nice i like to hear from them i
swear to god they used to have fresh
fuji apples on those salads i swear i
swear to god like
yeah well this will get more interesting
as listeners sort of start to hear the
i want everyone
i want i hope that everyone who calls in
works at panera bread
so you can ask
i just think that'd be interesting i
want somebody to come in with a hot take
oh here we go we have another column
i love it okay welcome to the always
sunny podcast you're on with rob charlie
and glenn
what do you got hi hi hi who are we who
are we speaking with today
uh my name is caitlin
hi caitlin caitlyn are you married to
rob mclanny
no not that kid
didn't wish you were married to rob
mcelhenny
to be honest i wish that rob and caitlin
were my parents oh so now people uncles
look guys we're gonna have to get used
to this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
not we're people's uncles or parents now
yeah we're no longer peers yeah you're
far too old for katelyn
what area of the world are you calling
us from today
uh i'm in wisconsin yes oh cool a lot of
midwest i love it the midwest calling in
and representing now do you have any
sort of uh
things to ask us you got any hot takes
you you want to take any stretches oh
he's really putting on a show today
you're really putting on a show today
i'm keeping it going i'm keeping it i'm
keeping the energy up
caitlyn talk to us
oh god i don't oh man
uh i will say just to to process
everything right now i i am
currently recovering from brain surgery
wow so i'm a little bit all over the
place right now okay so your brains your
brain is uh it's still healing
it is yeah yeah i just got some brain
surgery um a few days ago i guess maybe
do you guys have any recommendations for
i have been re-watching a lot of sunny
lately do you have any recommendations
for re-watches in this particular
situation
great question that is a very good
always fun to re-watch game of thrones
if you've only seen that once or not or
not at all that's talking about
no no you can do that do that also yeah
i'm just giving you recommendations for
other shows to watch to help your brain
heal yeah we are not normally i'll keep
those two recommended for brain growth
but i think you know if you were um
there's uh flowers for charlie is all
about uh oh yeah some intelligence and
good for laughs did you ever read the
book flowers for algernon in school
no i did not um but i am familiar with
the episode or maybe you have
and you don't remember it uh-oh
now hold on a second
i'm assuming that the surgery went well
but did you say it was just a couple of
days ago
uh yeah it was about a week ago now oh
that's so great you came out of the
brain
your brain is working part of it is the
speech part is yeah and the and you
dialed on the phone and you're on social
media okay so so caitlin what what
what's going on with your brain why did
you have to have brain surgery
um i went in because i had a really
severe migraine and then they did some
imaging on me and they found out that um
i a couple of my arteries like in the
back of my head were dissecting um so
they had to put a couple of stents in so
that was really fun wow
are they happy with the work are they
feeling that it was a successful
operation what were you told
they
yeah they are they are yeah i'm on a
bunch of blood thinners right now so
you sound great caitlyn you're a modern
miracle yeah okay did they have to shave
your head and all that
no it's oh my god i can't believe i'm
talking to you guys right now
did they go into the ear
they went through like my leg
it was weird
[Music]
now did you go see a doctor that knows
that your brain's not in your leg
i just want to be sure what are the
doctors in wisconsin doing yeah yeah did
you go to joe rogan for they're so
filled with jesus
they're so filled with cheese in
wisconsin that they think that your
brain is in your leg is that right
maybe i should have called into the joe
rogan podcast
this is amazing congratulations you
sound like a bad [ __ ] yeah yeah
one week later after brain surgery
you're calling into this dumb ass show
caleb well done we're happy it was been
good talking to you we have a whole line
of callers we got to get to thank you
for calling thank you for watching the
show good luck with your brain and your
blood
thank you so much i love you guys i'm
i've been obsessed with the show for
years it's been such a huge part of my
life so sincerely thank you
thank you caitlyn thank you so much
happy it all worked out for you all
right bye bye bye awesome that's the
kind of stuff that's going to happen you
know it's going to be two young women i
know i'm two young women well we have a
large female audience tonight too young
like 23 and yeah yeah i think maybe
maybe at some point maybe we were like
you know sexy young guys to now we're
just like
drunk uncles and parents and uncles and
parents it's like oh it's like listen to
my parents like that's what's going to
be a lot of calls today people like it's
like watching your shows like listening
to my parents bicker
welcome to the always sunny podcast
you're on with rob charlie and glenn
that's true you are what do you want
who's your name what do you want who is
this state your business
this is a this is zander and my my
business is uh
asking you a question i guess okay wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what xander the hotline are you but do
you spell that with an x at the
beginning
are you from xander
and is it zandor is it like xander the
great or is it just zandar straight up
zander yeah zarya zandar mars all right
xander from mars on the line xander go
ahead and ask us some questions what do
you want to know buddy
hey i want to know
this is something i've been wondering
for like a while
i want to know
if you would ever do an episode
where there's like a normal mcpoy you
know how the coils are all like [ __ ]
up and [ __ ] yeah well what if there was
an episode where there was just like a
normal coil like just there's nothing
wrong with this mcfoyle like to the fact
you don't even know to make coil at
first right
and then
you find out it's mccoy
we kind of did that tomorrow we kind of
did that we did that we yeah in the
invincible episode
is just to be like a tough football guy
we don't know that he's a football that
we don't know that he's mcpoyle and then
it's revealed that he's a big boy so i
feel yeah but i know what you're i know
what you're saying but yeah we're seeing
a little more buttoned up of a kind of a
character or like like somebody comes in
like ryan i know it's like ryan reynolds
awesome it's that for the ireland
episodes this year that day that
that's right caitlyn was going to be
dating a guy and then she's not an irish
doctor
and she finds out that it's amazing
so yeah yeah xander you're doing it to
something you know do you need a job and
the writers are you a writer
when you're not on mars
hey hey man i'm in birmingham alabama
all right
hey birmingham the coolest city in
alabama yeah glenn you spent a lot of
time in birmingham well montgomery but
montgomery
but i've spent quite a bit of time in
birmingham yeah close enough close
enough sure now xander how old are you
23. look at this
are you currently employed
yeah
there's a long gap what are you doing
what do you do zander zandari he's 23.
so he's fine in his way my guess is what
do you do
23. i work at amazon yeah he's finding
his way but i'm i this is interesting
because now we have somebody from i
think there's a common misconception
that our audience is like
coastal or college town
interesting we're in now this is
birmingham wisconsin and outside in in
rural michigan mm-hmm
we're learning we're all over the place
all right we're all over the place
xander thank you for calling in and
thank you for your uh your good question
about the show we appreciate them thank
you for your service at amazon do they
have you pissing in bottles when you're
when you're shipping [ __ ] or what what
do we got
yeah all the time yeah yeah god bless
you goodbye all right have a good day
thank you bye all right who's our next
couple we guys it's uh you know
fans which is good but but i think we're
going to need to what do you want to do
you want a crazy just a straight up
crazy person
yeah
that's what you want i do want a crazy
person called but no i i think it'd be
well no one knows what to expect right
here
we can find through this process what is
that we're looking for right and asking
the audience and say like hey we want
your hot take like bring us a hot take
yeah you know next time yeah
it might happen organically somebody
might just just we're learning we're
learning as we go yeah i love it i love
it let's take another call yeah okay
wait for that we've got waiting for the
thousands of calls
by the way again okay okay this is cool
okay wow uh
i wonder if they're gonna be any other
zandari is there a screening process for
this are they just putting down anything
i have uh yeah two people screening the
camera that's right yeah megan gave us
the whole rundown yeah you weren't
listening yeah but the listener
charlie and glenn [ __ ] dick sorry not
you caller i wasn't calling you a dick
hey who do we have on the line here who
are we speaking to
this is eddie lowe from long
a part where they don't have cell
service now eddie are you calling us
from a landline on a fishing boat
what do you got eddie you got a question
business you got any questions for us
eddie it's something you want to chat
about
yeah i just wanted to say you know i
freaking love you guys i've probably
seen the show
you know every season 100 times i'm like
obsessed man
well that's awesome i got a question for
you then eddie um
you know uh what do you think about
whoopi goldberg
whoopsie
yeah
there we go
whoopee
goldberg now let's oh i thought you
meant whoopsie goldberg now eddie on a
scale of one to ten one being sober and
ten being like stoned as as hell how
where are you on the spectrum right now
well
i'm like kind of on a permanent stone
yeah all right yeah okay i can feel that
that's great
now how much how much have we
i like it with the straight up you know
i like to see the bugs and i like that
you know old school old school you know
rituals yeah you like the ceremony are
you in your what what age range well how
old are you
i'm i just turned 30 this year oh
congratulations welcome to adults it's a
dark time for me yeah
it's fine
all right eddie we have thousands of
callers today so uh we're gonna move on
uh enjoy your hi thanks for calling in
and uh we're gonna go to the next call i
think god bless you eddie thanks for
watching the show eddie i love you man
love you man thanks for watching
you guys having fun
yeah yeah
we're hearing from
we're hearing from fans of the show it
feels it feels very good
pretty cool we don't really hear from
fans we don't really
hear we're just you know maybe just
walking around
certainly they don't just talk to fans
on the phone
i love it welcome to the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn hey
what's going on over there
yes hi megan oh hi
the megan fan all right all right you
spoke directly to megan who are we
speaking with tonight
first of all who are we speaking with
today
i'm daniella
are you on the [ __ ] wow okay cool are
you actually taking a [ __ ] are you
taking a [ __ ] or are you peeing
no i'm taking a [ __ ] this is nice this
is amazing that is amazing is it a good
one have you been are you hydrated or is
it is it coming out runny is it and is
it a mess you're gonna have to wipe a
thousand times or is nothing gonna come
out is it going okay or how are you
it's one of those where you like sit
down and then you kind of like get bored
and you're just like there and then i
called in and i was like no
you're gonna have to coax it out
you're gonna have to coax it out
well if you need to stop to push your
grunt that's fine yeah that's all well
yes i'm sorry and i i missed the first
part has any has any been um exported
yet
just like little little little little
dots
but you're looking at nuggets but you're
looking for right she's getting she's
getting milked up
she's getting milk duds and she wants a
fall snickers bar i'm sensing a
hydration problem here yeah
yeah i suggest that most
mornings this morning i gotta warm up
all right all right okay this is the
first one you hurt yourself she's
popping the cork sometimes this happens
right the first [ __ ] of the day i think
you all ruined it
now why is it a morning uh poop for you
where are you calling us from yeah are
you in hawaii i'm from i'm calling from
arizona okay okay 10 30 so it's not it's
kind of not late that's a young person's
morning you know what i mean like
we're old we're up at seven with the
kids yeah what's your question for megan
because megan megan deserves a question
any you can ask her anything and she
will tell you
okay uh megan um
have you done your bowel movement for
the day
this is amazing this is wild uh
yeah yeah i don't bring anything into
this room other than enthusiasm
for these guys that's right yeah yeah
yeah you can't have poop in your body
and do a podcast
we're so lucky to have her
yeah we know we know we don't uh i have
a follow-up question megan which podcast
did you call into while you were uh
yeah who do you usually call it yeah i i
don't know i keep it to myself okay yeah
yeah that's fair okay well listen we
hope that you can get a nice full
snickers bars worth of poop out yeah we
hope you have a full evacuation you know
what i mean complete elimination yeah
thank you guys y'all made my day y'all
like and then it's just started this is
fantastic
all right well enjoy your bowel movement
and thanks for calling the sunny podcast
thank you all right
are you having a good weekend
[Laughter]
all right now see that's the she left
laughing it's fun that's great she left
laughing she brought in do you think
she's really pooping i don't think she's
really good with you know excitement
do you think she really was i think she
was i think she was i think people like
put a joke out there and then they're
like oh i gotta stick with it maybe
maybe i thought that was a good i
thought that you know i don't know i
think she might have been
she might have been she's
she sat down in the toilets like oh i'm
going to call this thing she's like i'm
getting she was well yeah she was
checking her instagram which people
often do on the [ __ ] toilet and she saw
our poster there may be a fair the only
time i think i ever look at social media
is when i'm on the toilet when you're
there this person could be on the toilet
as well
all right welcome to the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn are you on the [ __ ] who do we
have right now who's speaking you know i
was actually waiting i just finished
okay i'm telling you this is gonna
happen more often than we think okay
this is it because that's when people
are looking at their phones yeah they're
on the shoulder did it go well for you
did you have a good movement and uh
well
once once i got the call uh or once they
picked up saying that uh i'll get
transferred
um i kind of just did a half-ass wipe
and
you know i didn't want that i didn't
want that echo to affect the podcast oh
after this you'll wipe the other half of
your ass yeah well let me let me ask you
something man um
first of all what's your name
my name is wilson hey wilson uh cool
name um
so question for you uh do you just do
you just use toilet paper and that's it
or do you use baby wipes i know some
people use baby wipes
no i do use the disposable
uh wipes the flushable ones the flush
you're not messing up your pipes are you
flushable
where do you live wilson
i live in uh hollywood at the moment
hollywood what do you do are you in the
biz are you in the biz i am not in the
business but um i'm actually a nurse so
whenever um i actually listen to your
guys's podcast on the way uh to work and
then
uh on the way home from work so awesome
yeah
you know yeah long time listener you
know first time caller
wilson you work in the hospital
i do work in the hospital yeah i'm in
the emergency room
wow how many how many gun shots do you
see a day
oh that's a good one um we get a lot of
walk-ins we're uh [ __ ] walking in
having been shot
cars cars pull cars pull up
and dump someone at the curb yeah my
friend yeah they dumped somebody there
they don't come in with them they don't
park well no it's not some sort of a
legal shooting situation they don't want
the cops asking a bunch of questions
right
yeah as soon as they uh drop them off
they uh kind of just scurry away
afterwards but uh i've seen quite a few
gunshots
but how many on average are you seeing
today i'm dead serious
you can well let's say for a week i work
four days a week um you could probably
average
about like
four to six uh within that week wow
that's only on my shift so you know you
get like one here two and sometimes in a
row and generally what what shift are
you working then it's quite
what are your hours what are your hours
uh i'm graveyard so oh
wow so
wilson i do have a very serious question
to ask you you know we're talking about
kovid we're talking about you know gun
uh usage and stuff um
what percentage of people are coming
into the er with things stuck into their
asses that are they can't get out right
things that they've lodged in their
[ __ ]
like i've got a leg i've got a lego in
there i swear to god my kid did it i
thought it'd be fun to have this in my
[ __ ] and i'm finding out that it's
not that's really a rare occasion there
um but uh i've seen things stuck in
vaginas oh okay okay so you haven't seen
a lot of ass play what's the weirdest
thing you've seen stuck in a vagina
uh multiple tampons
oh well that's just sad
heavy glow for happy face
they actually forgot about them they
just didn't know what their stomach was
hurting oh
[Music]
my god oh
god i would just like to point out that
you've just talked about [ __ ] for like
so long with no gross reaction and then
tampons are mentioned and you guys know
it was sad it was sad it was sad that it
wasn't someone's sexual ambition turned
into a comedic tragedy
it was it was
it was sad that you know someone was
trying to stop sexual ambition
wilson we have a lot of callers today
but thank you for your your uh service
and uh yeah and you're listening
oh yeah no thank you guys for
entertaining uh you know me while i uh
head home and you know i have to
de-stress a little bit you got it buddy
a lot so i appreciate you guys happy to
be here workers man yeah
thank you thank you all right see you
wilson bye bye
great well now i thought there would be
more stuff in people's asses i would
have thought it's not a shame it's not a
huge surprise
is that what am i seeing there my phone
oh my god i thought that was your skin i
was like i thought
do you guys know why i thought that
because i have
another friend who works in the er in
rhode island who said all the time
people come in was [ __ ] their asses
stuck in their asses so apparently in la
we know how to get stuff out of our
asses well
if you put the right thing in there the
right shaped thing in there because
that's what you want and then you
shouldn't have any problem getting it
out always have a backup plan too tie
string to it i think the ass has a
locking tie a [ __ ] string i think the
ass has a locking mechanism that once
it's gone in it's like a vacuum that's
why you need the string i know but
you're gonna make it worse if you pull
it out well it doesn't work yes if you
put those if you put like you know barbs
in it that go backwards it's like a
chinese um
finger finger trap like what's that uh
yeah
harder you pull the tighter again yeah
yeah yeah
anyway rob we're gonna are we getting is
that the [ __ ] is that how the [ __ ]
works it's like a chinese finger trap
yeah that's right here rob is this too
blue for you
are you
are you are you getting are you getting
embarrassed are you getting
are you getting close i don't want to be
the pee pee poo [ __ ] guy oh i know
yeah that's true let's talk about
something wholesome
no not awesome but just we went no
whatever i'm i'm into it okay all right
megan let's take another call let's
let's let's talk [ __ ]
you really should be over there eating
crackers though like frank and the
afternoon
it would be cool
it would be cool if you were doing an
art thing plugging that thing into it
you can get a prop like switchboard
whatever you want to probably
like do this that'd be fun i always
wanted to be that yeah just a moment
just a moment love just a moment
one moment welcome to the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn
what is going on
hello caller what do you got hi hello
what's up who are we speaking with
speaking with
uh my name is will fredo
will fray alfredo is that is that your
first name or is that both names
that is my first name i get that a lot
but it is my first name all right who
are you calling us from today
i'm calling from new york
all right we're part of new york
new york state new york city
uh new york city i'm actually currently
at my job
[Music]
where do you work listen i saw the tweet
i saw the tweet and i was like i'm gonna
call i'm gonna put my headphones in you
know i have long hair i could hide it
i'm getting away with it
are you going to get fired if your boss
knows you don't get if you're you're on
a on a talk show right now
or whatever this is oh i'm not going to
get fired oh you're you're he's an
essential he's essential to the
organization exactly where you are but
like what kind of business is it yeah
what do you do yeah it's retail okay oh
yeah so you can do it every time okay
what's the deal are you selling shirts
you selling sandwiches what are you
doing
yeah it's clothes i work at uh yeah i
work at a i'm
are you in one of the big fancy fifth
avenue ones or are you you know no no no
no no no okay all right okay you're just
talking yourself right now are you out
on the floor right now talking to
yourself
yeah are you on the floor no
i'm i'm a back stock guy that's why i
feel so confident in getting away with
this
okay guys are you standing living on the
edge man i bet you can fold the [ __ ] out
of a shirt can't you way to go dude
do you have one of those would you have
one of those like square plastic things
that you fold a shirt on or do you just
[ __ ] do it by hand
oh we have them buddy i don't need them
yes
that is a skill for life because that
applies not only to work but also home
life you know you can have a nice drawer
full of really well folded clothes well
fredo wait wait hold on a second now can
you fold a shirt expertly without
actually laying it out on the table can
you just do it by hand on your [ __ ]
chest and your stomach can you do that
oh yeah i can do it full-on in the air
buddy
that by the way would be an amazing
trick if you could just figure out how
to [ __ ] throw it in the air like a
pizza and it would land in your hand
like a like all that would be the
greatest you would be an internet
what's your favorite episode of this
show oh wow oh interesting i don't know
just learning the panda okay i don't
know that's a that's a good question um
i will say
because
of its most recent airing
i will say
um
[Music]
the
finale of the newest season oh
thank you man was it uh charlie's oscar
winning uh
uh emotional performance at the end or
was it the the chuckles that you got no
that's exactly that's exactly what it
was for me um that's what i love about
this show you know it has so much art um
within like the mess of what the show is
and um
on my break i was watching the episode
and i started crying
do you have a tough relationship with
your father wilfredo
what was that what how is your
relationship with your father
oh uh it's it's good my relationship
with my father is good not as of late
uh-oh okay but
yeah my parents are going through a
thing oh yeah are they going through a
divorce
no but they should be okay okay
that means a lot to us that's what we're
trying to do we're trying to make you
happy we're sad
yeah i think especially because i just
came back from a trip from el salvador
and i was with my parents and my sisters
and we had a bunch of time together
and that trip for me and my father kind
of strained our relationship a little
bit
so coming back and watching this episode
i was like oh i did i did not know those
uh those feelings were in there but they
came out oh that's good
that's good that means you care about
emotional release how old are you
i'm 29.
yeah right young man well listen i hope
things uh you know improve between your
parents or or that they go through with
the divorce and things improve after
that uh but uh you know there's always
plenty of time to get your relationship
back on track with your dad
yeah i hope that absolutely
hey listen buddy thanks for calling in
um and i'm i'm glad i haven't been
caught the entire time all right don't
get fired wilfredo
yeah all right good luck buddy see you
then call your dad
yeah see you
guys we've had 5 608 callers so far
so that's a lot of callers when you're
ready for another one we're ready all
right let's go all right
welcome to the always sunny podcast
you're on with rob charlie and glenn
hello well hello
hello
hello boys oh my god how are you
who are you speaking with today
my name is dina a very long long long
time sunny viewer and big fan how are
you guys oh my god we're good how long
dina how old are you
i'm okay well you're going to think i'm
a child because i'm 21. oh wow
okay
yes essentially i was watching the gang
uh the ken gets racist when i was
probably way too young oh yeah oh yeah
yeah how old were you and what was your
impression at the time did you think it
was funny right away or did it take you
a second to kind of key into the humor
i mean okay of course it took a little
bit for me to be like okay are these
guys actually bad individuals are trying
to poke fun at stuff here um but the
first episode i watched it alone which i
think is the best kind of experience to
have with that episode because you know
you're like should i be laughing
should i not be laughing right now
you don't want to be judged um
but no it definitely it it hit me funny
right away i mean i didn't watch the
first season in bed i'm currently sick
with cobin right now and been binge
watching i mean i literally watched
every season every day
well listen what kind of variant do you
have which variant do you have do you
have the delta you got the homework
how do you know how do you know how do
you know okay
well with the delta it's more supposed
to be respiratory and okay so
and you use your taste and smell so i
have taste and smell my girlfriend
tested positive like three days ago i
tested negative actually but i'm like
sick so i'm looking at lost but here's
the classic here's the thing i don't
have an original i don't mean to stir
things up or anything here but uh
like the logic you bring the right
questions like
well he's the host
i love you do not get me wrong and rob
you're my favorite character so get her
out
there
we're just we're just kidding
[Laughter]
a regular
i was born in new york i've been in
philly plenty of times but um yeah but
no i grew up in north carolina for the
most part what do you do for work dana
well i'm actually i'm 21 so i'm in my
final year of uh college i'm studying
french and english
all right and hopefully trying to move
overseas one day i don't know listen
your english is great yeah so yeah i
don't know where you're from but you got
the english part i wouldn't worry too
much about that thank you if i'm your
favorite character i will say that
you're my favorite college yeah and i
will say you have terrible tastes but i
don't know no no no
she has she did not lose her sense of
taste she has a different strength she
didn't say she that rob you were her
favorite actor that she lost her smile
she didn't lose her sense of smell she
clearly lost her sense of taste
[Music]
welcome to the always sunny podcast
you're on with rob charlie and glenn
hi
hello
hi hi oh my
god who are we speaking with today my
name is josiah i am just super thrilled
that i actually made it on today
josiah
where are you calling from josiah
uh grand rapids michigan it's oh my god
josiah give us a hot take yeah man yeah
yeah give us a take yeah what's going on
what do you want to talk about the earth
round or flat okay round the flat earth
go
uh it's it's definitely flat that's for
sure okay
good all right i like this guy right
absolutely and then our parts of it
round
um the good parts are okay okay okay
okay
flat earther from michigan
what's up man
so much man just actually at work right
now i uh supposed to be going into a
meeting and i was like i've got a very
important call that i'm on hold for so
oh
what are you meeting about are you the
ceo are they just [ __ ] sitting there
tapping their you know
fingers on the counter waiting for you
to show up
nah dude i'm just a sales guy but um i'm
gonna just hopefully
uh not lose my job because i'm going to
be late for that but i really honestly
this is worth it buddy if you are
selling whatever it is you're selling on
the regular you're not going to lose
your job what are you selling
oh i know i hope it's not globes
it's not what i was not i'm selling
earth coins flat globes
i wish it was uh no i mean we uh we do a
lot of uh i.t and cyber security uh for
west michigan which apparently is a big
thing so that's what we do oh okay all
right
gotta keep the russians out got to keep
the russians out good for you okay you
got a question for us or
what's going on
which one of you guys is most like your
character on the show
um none of us really i mean none of us
honestly that that that that's the truth
yeah
i mean we all have aspects of ourself
that we bring to the character but i
don't know i mean man who do you glenn's
got to take though
who's your what's your take well i i
just was thinking like i do
sometimes i mean
yeah i mean there's there's aspects of
my personality that are in the country
i was going to say
you know what it is the the frustration
the the extreme frustration over little
things that i shouldn't get so bent out
of shape about that i share with the
character the the overall i could see
that yeah like but uh all the other
stuff no i mean i'm i'm not uh i'm not
like that guy i'm not like that guy's
pretty crazy you know the amount of
times i scream uh idiots and savages on
a daily basis
yeah it applies to so much that's the
thing though it applies there are a lot
of idiots and savages out there
charlie
how did that was i feel like that was
something that you came up with when we
were writing that episode
that you kind of because that was the
first time i feel like my character ever
truly ranted and raved well see the
thing is i i think i get to channel some
of my psychosis through your character
too which is a fun thing which is
sometimes i'm like well i sometimes feel
crazy like a maniac but it's not gonna
it's not gonna seem right like but can i
pitch you some stuff but i don't know i
don't totally recall that that might i
seem to recall it being you having a
very specific thing you were like
i
think glenn can do this i think he's got
this gear
and you wrote this thing and it where i
just went absolutely crazy and you told
me you were just like go nut just go
[ __ ] nuts yeah and i was like all
right let's just try it let's see what
happens every once in a while you'll
come to us and be like guys i just don't
feel like we i want to go like in this
direction and we'll be like okay okay
okay and then we'll just like write it
and then you'll be like i don't know if
i want to do it like come on man just do
it just do it and it's always funny it
gets funnier and funnier yeah
it is good jesus josiah you should get
your meeting don't get fired while we
compliment glenn yeah i will try my best
not to couple many times um
we'll kind of see what happens from okay
i mostly also just have to pee and i've
just been like oh go pee don't don't
all right listen man uh we're not gonna
wait for you to pee uh but uh we love
you and thank you for calling him
thank you guys
guys are we ever gonna go back to just
talking about the episodes like this is
too fun this is way fun and i think if
we get a little structure to it and we
come up with some some questions or yeah
i think i think i think we every once in
a while we just do one of these why not
yeah the [ __ ] not too fun
yeah we should do a whole episode where
we have people call in and tell us what
we're doing wrong yeah absolutely
absolutely yes we have themes right so
so like this episode you call and you
tell us what we've done wrong yeah this
episode for example they'll say don't
hit the table when you're talking right
but it could be about what we're doing
wrong with the podcast it could be what
we're doing wrong with the show right
could be what we're doing wrong in life
yes
welcome to the always sunny podcast
you're on with rob charlie and glenn you
sure are you got through you sure are
you got you did it you might be our last
call amazing it could be our last call
we'll see
could be the last call wow yeah you know
we'll do more of these but we can only
do something for today in one day for
today yeah what's your name man
um jimbo how are you guys doing jimbo
jimbo is it on the driver's license
jimbo or is jimbo a
nickname oh no it's just total fake name
i just totally made it up oh
[ __ ] man i'm from alabama i thought
maybe that was your real name because
you're worried that you're going to get
like some hot water for being on this or
you want to just oh yeah
because you're at work what part of the
country are you calling from jimbo can
you give that out
i'm calling from chicago all right
jimbo we are a midwest show i love it
almost everybody who's called in has
been from the midwest there was a couple
of exceptions but almost everyone else
was from the midwest yeah it's wild
jimbo what's going on
right now it's cold out we got snow yeah
nothing to do but sit inside and call
you guys all right all right
so what do you want yeah jimbo you're
you're lying about your name why what
have you done yeah what's your agenda
what have you
is the government looking for you uh are
are you on the run are the monsters
looking for you jimbo
ma do you say monsters yeah yeah yeah
the monsters yeah yeah the monsters
you guys aren't tracking my location on
the call are you we
are we are triangulating as we speak
that's right they're gonna get you
because we know where you are they say
triangulate they do a series of
triangles to get someone's yeah they can
they can yeah why don't they circular
circular right somewhat i think i think
what it is is like a triangle you need a
tr you need that you need the least you
can right look if you picture a triangle
like the three dots of of the ends of a
triangle
and you then you go straight to the
center of that that's where the guy is
by the way they're on they're on their
way to your house right now
how much time do i got guys
two minutes i'd say two minutes jimbo
you have any questions for us
what do you want jimbo what are your
dreams yeah tell us about your dreams
is to be on the show someday oh are you
an actor
are you are you an actor
jimbo i want you know when i was a
little kid you know we used to make some
stupid home movies uh so it's about the
extent of my acting career oh that was
hey listen that's what we did we made a
stupid home movie and although most
people who appear on our show jimbo have
dedicated their lives to uh being
performers well that's true yeah
competition but you're here on our our
our podcast which is in a sense like
being on the show yeah what is this the
kind of performance you would give on
the show
uh
you know it depends what kind of
character i'd be you know i imagine you
guys would probably just have me being
you know some guy in the corner for half
a second shot so mm-hmm
we might be able to pull that off but we
don't know who you are well jim jimbo
this has been fun
jimbo we're gonna have to let you go but
only because uh we're out of time we're
out of time
you're out of time all right well i
think i got another minute before uh the
authorities get me yeah yeah yeah yeah
grab your go bag go ahead for the fire
escape i know it's chilly out there so
bring a coat make sure you have your
socks and shoes on you have a go bag
you're gonna want to scuttle down that
fire escape with as little noise as
possible if there's a trash can or
something you can plumb it in two that's
going to be good for a softer layer
just hop right into the trash right with
my go bag be good to go okay get out of
here
yeah okay great well hey listen for
watching that's a lot i have a feeling
they're going to catch you but best of
luck bye jimbo thanks for calling all
right i'm fast i'm fat all right
all right let's get going all right see
you pal
well guys have we done it
is this
this is uh you know
it's the first one i yeah i think once
we come up with a little bit more
structure i think i like the idea of
there being a specific theme to the
calling right
all right so i think that's it and uh
yeah let's call it a podcast we'll call
it a podcast and we'll do it again
oh
um
hello
hey that's steven spielberg it's your
old buddy hey guys how's it going today
i heard you guys were doing a call and
show got very excited about it great
idea by the way very original and uh
yeah nobody's ever done that i don't
think right i mean uh i'm i'm sorry
steven the guy's already left
uh are you [ __ ] kidding me megan
seriously you put me through the guys
aren't even there
god damn it i was gonna put him in my
next movie